[Musik]
an der heerstraße in berlin soll der
neue radweg gebaut werden der alte aus
den siebziger jahren ist für radler eine
zumutung und obendrein lebensgefährlich
deshalb hat die stadt entlang der straße
schon mal 61 bäume gefällt die erzählte
alte recht die gebäude aber jetzt heißt
es auf einmal der geplante radweg wird
nicht gebaut
für mich ist es eine echte katastrophe
dass man hier einfach die bäume weg
gemacht hat ohne dass was passiert
erinnert so ein erster april absolut
bekloppt total scheiße ist es dann dazu
kamen sie abzuholzen waren wir alle
radfahrer die auch im kiez sind total
entsetzt vor knapp zwei jahren plant die
stadt berlin den maroden radweg an der
heerstraße zu erneuern damit die
bauarbeiten beginnen können werden
fakten geschaffen um die bäume links und
rechts der straße gefällt aber kaum sind
die bäume weg wird das projekt gestoppt
der grund das neue berliner mobilitäts
gesetz berlin will irgendwann mal ganz
breite und schicke radwege bauen wann
völlig unklar
für die heerstraße heißt das hier
passiert das mal gar nichts denn der
eigentlich geplante radweg passt nicht
ins konzept für die bäume ist das leider
zu spät denn die sind ja weg für den bnd
berlin ein ganz schlechter scherz zu
lasten der natur diesem fall war das ein
absolut unsinnige aktion eben weil sie
sich nicht rechtzeitig hingesetzt haben
gewartet haben ist die gesamte planung
auf dem tisch liegt und dann erst
sorgfältig gearbeitet haben dass die
fällaktion viel zu voreilig war räumt
man selbst in der zuständigen berliner
senatsverwaltung 1
es ist natürlich auch ein großer
planungsfehler der nun hätte gleich die
alten planung auf den prüfstand nehmen
müssen als das neue gesetz haben und
dass es nicht passiert den behördlichen
planungsfehler haben die berliner
straßen bäume nicht überlebt für viele
hauptstädter ein absolutes unding also
ich denke mal wenn das wirklich menschen
sind die dafür bezahlt werden für seine
planung ist das sehr peinlich
ja das kann doch nicht wahr sein
ziemlich nervige sache davon abgesehen
hat es sehr schade dass um die bäume
auch für die radfahrer schwitzen in der
sonne wo man früher schön schatten hatte
das ist für mich ohne sinn und verstand
da hat wieder mal
zu früh geschaltet denke ich mal die
bäume abgesägt ohne einfach nachzudenken
wann an der berliner heerstraße endlich
ein schöner breite radweg gebaut wird
kann uns keiner sagen aber die natur
schlägt zurück denn die baumstümpfe
treiben wieder aus
jetzt müssen sie jahr für jahr gestützt
werden damit die wege frei bleiben und
nicht komplett zu buche satte 2000 euro
werden für diesen grünschnitt jedes mal
fällig